the attention of world agencies at this moment is
riveted on the events in andy moscow in the
metropolitan area about this object the city
introduced martial law
adjacent to the street closed to
traffic local residents were evacuated
nevertheless many refused to leave I
remind you that 232 people became victims of the incident,
dozens are reported
missing in  more than 500 wounded remain in hospitals
I don’t like what’s happening I do
n’t like it, we just don’t do anything
archive we have options we can dump
where we can’t stand it we can all
say this is our land this is our
land
version today in the south of the capital you can
observe a rare cosmic phenomenon
west entered the object is moving our
side with controlled